The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So what's important
the last couple of lectures?
Christina.
AUDIENCE: Transfer functions.
PROFESSOR: Transfer
functions, all right.
How about something else?
AUDIENCE: Modal coordinates.
PROFESSOR: Modal coordinates.
And I'll expand that to call
this modal analysis in general.
Anything else?
Well, think more about that.
And are there any questions
for the week, anything muddy,
fuzzy, not quite
clear to you that if I
have time to say a
few words about today
you'd like me to talk about?
AUDIENCE: So I guess I'm
a little bit confused
with what we did in
class, the modal analysis.
Is that just like-- so when we
did originally Newton's law,
and then we did the [INAUDIBLE].
Is that sort of
similar here where
we can do either the
things in motion,
or we can do
[INAUDIBLE] analysis?
PROFESSOR: Is modal analysis
an alternative way of--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The analogy
isn't too helpful.
But modal analysis is
one way of attacking
the equations of
motion that describe
vibration of linear systems.
You can work through
the entire analysis
and figure out the solution
to the equations of motion.
And usually with these multiple
degree of freedom vibration
problems, you can cast
them as a mass matrix
times an acceleration vector
plus a stiffness matrix
times a displacement vector
equals some forcing function.
So these are-- and
we linearize them.
And we know they're
for vibration problems.
We can solve these equations
using modal analysis.
Or we can solve them
brute force directly
without breaking the results
into their modal contributions.
And so there really are
two kinds of approaches
you can use to doing it.
Any other kind of questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for a
definition of mode shape,
is mode shape just the
ratio of the two amplitudes?
PROFESSOR: In the case of a
two degree of freedom system,
so mode shapes for mode n of
an n degree of freedom system--
like let's say n equals 3 here.
So for mode n, the mode
shape you always have
to present some normalization.
I do the normalization
oftentimes by just saying, OK,
I'm going to make the top
coordinate-- I'm going
to give it unit amplitude.
So I'm going to take a1
and divide it by itself.
And that'll give me a 1.
Then every other one, this
becomes a2 over a1, a3 over a1.
The mode shape says if this
is then 1 minus 1/2 and a 1/4,
it says that if
generalized coordinate
1 moves a unit amount,
generalized coordinate 2
will move half of that in
its negative direction.
This could be an
x, a displacement,
and that could be a rotation.
But they all have positively
defined directions.
So if there's a positive 1
at x1, there's a minus 1/2
at generalized coordinate
2, and there's a plus 1/4 at
generalized coordinate 3.
And that ratio stays
constant for the mode.
And so if it's an initial
condition problem,
and you set it up so
that you actually give it
an exhibit, just an
initial displacement,
of exactly that shape, it'll
sit there and vibrate only
in that mode.
And you'll notice
that proportion,
even as it dies out with
damping, of the first
to the other two stays
exactly constant.
That's what a mode is.
And it's a character.
It's a property of the system.
The natural frequency
is a property.
And the shape of every mode
is a property of that system.
OK, anything else, questions?
Next lecture, we'll do
more modal analysis.
We did the response to
initial conditions yesterday.
Tuesday, we'll talk about the
response to external forces.
And that will give us a chance
to review it and post it
on Stellar.
Last night, I put up a
little two page sheet
that is a cookbook,
how to do the procedure
of a modal analysis.
It's very cookbook, just step
by step, bang, bang, bang.
And everything falls out.
Any other questions, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is that where
we get the mode shape from?
PROFESSOR: You
get the mode shape
by solving the
characteristic-- if you're
doing it by hand, by solving the
characteristic equation, which
we're going to get
some practice at today.
So I think this is
the exercise of today,
is how to get natural
frequencies and mode shapes.
AUDIENCE: Then you'd
be actually controlling
the amount that-- isn't the
mode shape actually drawing
some sort of graph?
PROFESSOR: As a graph that
shows the displacement of it,
or it shows the time history?
AUDIENCE: Either, I guess.
Because in the book,
they have mode shape.
But actually using this,
they draw a certain graph.
PROFESSOR: Sometimes they do.
If it's easy, like for
a vibrating string,
it's easy to draw
the mode shape.
AUDIENCE: And the piece
that they ask us to do that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and so
vibrating string, first mode
vibration looks like
half a sign wave.
The mode shape is just
half the sine wave
going up and down in space.
For this system, the mode shape
has two different amplitudes
at these two bobs.
And their relative motion we're
going to figure that out today.
OK, we better get going
or we won't finish.
So good questions.
And here's this system
simplified, just into two
bobs and massless strings.
Here's the equations
of motion for that.
They've been linearized already.
There's no sine
thetas or anything.
And part of the linearization--
so this assumes,
then, small amplitudes, right?
Not only did the sine--
the torque for a pendulum,
you get this mgL
sine theta term.
And so the linearization,
you say small angles,
sine theta becomes theta.
So that's where this g/L sine
theta has become theta term.
There's another
assumption that's
been made to model this system.
We're essentially
modeling the system.
And that is for
small angles, we're
assuming the spring
remains horizontal.
Because the spring puts
a force on the rod.
And what you want is
torque about that point.
These two equations
are the equations
for torque about that
point and about that point.
And the torque is the spring
force times that distance.
And if they're perpendicular,
that's just one times
the other.
But if it doesn't
remain perpendicular,
then you'd have
to take a cosine.
And it gets really messy.
So another part of this
small angle approximation
is that spring stays horizontal.
There's your equation of motion.
And you can see what's
happened here is that this
used to have an m1 L1 squared.
This is the mass moment
of inertia of that mass.
We've divided through the
equation by m1 L1 squared.
And that's put things in
the bottom here like that.
And it just makes this actually
a little easier to work with.
The mass matrix turns out
to be 1, 1 when you do this.
But it's still the same
two equations of motion.
I've just divided through by m1
L squared, and this one by m2 L
squared.
So these are your
equations of motion.
And your job is to
come up-- first of all,
just put them in matrix form.
And you're going to
do this in groups.
Today we've got five,
10, and 18 people.
So that's probably
four groups of four.
Work together in groups quickly.
Let's put up the
equations of motion
from this in matrix form.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: In your
lower left matrix?
Is the-- oh, the k.
I'm worried about the m.
AUDIENCE: The k's don't have
any symbols. it's just m2.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
Yeah, it's just one.
There's a single k.
There's only one spring,
so we just call it k.
All right, you're all
looking pretty good to me.
And the last hour, we
did this, and it went up,
and I looked at
it, and I just had
one of these moments of just,
uhh, cognitive dissonance.
It just was, how can
that possibly be?
And the reason was
this stiffness matrix.
This matrix is not diagonal--
excuse me, wrong word.
This matrix is not symmetric.
And linear stiffness matrices
are always symmetric.
So I saw this, and I
said, what has gone wrong?
Every one of you
had the same answer.
Every one of you, your stiffness
matrices are not symmetric.
It's minus k over m1
and minus k over m2.
And I about had heart
failure, and I've
been doing this for 40 years.
And it's always been symmetric.
And all of a sudden, you guys
unanimously get asymmetric.
So I figured it out
at great relief.
We divided through by m1 L1
squared in the first equation,
and m2 L2 squared in
the second equation.
The stiffness matrix, the
true stiffness matrix,
hasn't been divided
through by the mL squareds.
And it is indeed symmetric.
It's one of the things that's
really helpful to know.
Because when you're
working these things out,
you know they're symmetric.
You don't have to
evaluate all the terms.
You only have to do the
diagonals and half of the ones.
The mass matrices are
usually symmetric, too.
There's maybe some
exceptions if you
start putting in gyroscopes
and stuff like that.
But then it's not very linear.
So your next task
is to-- the way
we find natural
frequencies and mode
shapes is kind of the
hard way, using algebra,
is to find what we call the
characteristic equation.
It turns out to
be a fourth order
equation, omega to the fourth.
Find it.
Don't solve it, just write down
the characteristic equation
for this thing.
And as soon as you have that,
come up and write it down.
So remember, you
basically have matrices.
This is what you're
working with.
You've got something
of this form.
We've divided through by
some stuff to collect terms.
But how do you go about going
from the equations of motion
to your algebraic equation
in omega to the fourth?
I just want you to write up
the characteristic equation.
You're going to get a quadratic
in omega to the fourth.
Just go up and write
down the equation.
AUDIENCE: So do you
want us to expand?
PROFESSOR: By expand,
what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
multiply this by this?
But we could also
expand that out.
PROFESSOR: Well, I want
an equation in omega
to the fourth.
Just write one up there.
And if you want to simplify the
writing, you can let h equal--
and let's see, I forgot
the tell you something,
a key assumption
here, a key thing.
I was going to make
it easier for you.
Let--
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to say the m's are equal?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
sorry, my mistake.
Let the m's be equal.
Then it makes it a lot easier.
And then you can say,
call h g/L plus k/m.
And it'll kind of make the
equation a whole lot easier
to write.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Great, OK, people
are getting all the same answers
here, good.
So the next step is I will
give you-- if you solve this,
you get omega 1 is g/L.
Omega 1 squared is g/L.
And omega 2 squared
is g/L plus 2k over m.
Those are your two
natural frequencies.
So now, find the mode shapes.
Find the mode shapes.
If you know the natural
frequencies, now you go back in
and you get a-- pardon?
Yeah, keep h.
I think h will-- things will
fall out rather quickly.
Well, I like to
normalize the mode shapes
so the top one is 1.
And so the top element
of the mode shape
vector I call a1, or
u1, down through un.
And so if you divide out
each one by the top one,
the top one becomes 1.
The second one
becomes a2 over a1.
The third one, if it's
three degrees of freedom,
would be a3 over a1.
The fact that this-- you
just solve this equation.
To get that characteristic
determinant,
you said this was true.
And that's a particular
kind of situation
where you have a set
of linear homogeneous
equations equal to 0.
They're not independent.
Remember from algebra when
you have little equations
with constant coefficients, and
they're equal to a constant,
and the constants are
all 0, means they are not
independent equations.
So this is two equations
and two unknowns.
And they're not independent.
You won't be able to solve
for unique values of a1, u1,
and u2.
You'd only be able
to get the ratio.
So basically you
found this value.
You're going to plug in
a value for omega squared
and find out the values
of a1 and a2 that work.
That's what the mode shapes are.
Let me pull you back
together here, and let's
run through this
kind of quickly.
You've basically
solved this equation.
You've said, I'm going
to assume this thing has
a mode shape and a
frequency, a harmonic-- it's
going to vibrate.
It's undamped.
So either you could write this
as cosine omega t, sine omega
t, e to the i omega t.
But it has some constants
out here called the shape.
You plug that into the
equations of motion,
you're going to get
back this expression.
The two derivatives,
the theta double dots,
give you the minus
omega squareds.
And you can write it like that.
You can throw away the
e to the i omega t.
In this case, I've expand this.
m is just that 1, 1 matrix.
So this part looks like this.
The k matrix looks like this.
You can add them
element by element.
So this is minus omega
squared plus h, minus k/m.
This one is minus k/m, and
this term is minus omega
squared plus h again times
u1 or u2, the two elements
that we're looking for.
That's two equations.
This is just now an
algebraic equation,
two algebraic equations-- this
time u1 minus k/m times u2.
And the second equation is that.
And we know there's only
two equations, and not
linearly independent.
So you actually only
have one useful equation.
If this is a three by three,
they're not independent.
But you need to use
two out of the three.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
get the second equation?
PROFESSOR: The second
one, I take the first one,
and I multiply it up here.
And that gives me an equation,
this times u1 plus this times
u2.
That's equation one.
I take this, and I
multiply it by that.
And I get minus k/m u2.
And this is u1.
This is the omega squared.
I plugged in the
natural frequency.
So we solved for it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, OK.
But for the top one, you didn't
plug in the natural frequency.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
minus omega squared.
OK, I'm picking one of the
natural frequencies, g/L.
So this up here is g/L
plus h u1, that one.
And down here it's g/L h u2.
And you see, these two
equations turn out to be--
AUDIENCE: So this
is just for omega 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
only do it one at a time.
You just plug in one of
the natural frequencies.
And you get two equations
and two unknowns.
And they're going
to each give you
exactly the same information.
They're not
independent any longer.
So you solve this one.
h has what in it?
A plus g/L and a plus k/m.
The g/L is canceled.
And you're left with k/m
u1 minus k/m u2 equals 0.
And this implies
that u1 equals u2.
This is the g/L in this.
I'm going to plug
in the-- that is h.
I just put it in here.
I've plugged in one of the
natural frequencies squared.
The g/L parts cancel.
This is plus k/m
u1 minus k/m u2.
That means k/m u1 equals k/m u2.
Cancel out the k/m's.
I get that.
It just tells me that
that's the answer.
And if that's the answer,
the vector looks like u1, u2.
That's also equal to-- factor
out a u1-- u1 times 1 and u2
over u1.
That's the mode shape
there, 1 and u2 over u1.
That's how you factor it out to
put it in the normalized form.
You just take whatever's
in the top one and divide
everything in the column by it.
So to do the second
equation, you just
now go back to this, plug
in for omega 2 squared.
The second natural frequency
is g/L plus 2k over m.
This is g/L minus k/m.
The k over m's cancel.
And you're just left with g/L's.
You work this
through, you're going
to find out that u2
equals minus u1 if you
put in the second one.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we have a1 over a2,
b1 over b2, being equal to 1,
obviously.
Because b1 is equal to b2.
But I don't
understand the format
that you're writing it up there.
Because if you plug back in the
u, then you just get u1 over u2
is equal to u1 over u2.
And that's
self-explanatory, right?
PROFESSOR: Well,
when you solve this,
you find that k/m
u1 equals k/m u2.
That's just saying in this
case they are equal, period.
And that's all you learn.
You only have two equations.
And they're not independent.
So it means you only
have one equation.
And you don't learn--
you're not able to solve
for numeric values of u1 and u2.
At best, you can get u1 over u2.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
they're equal to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, and in fact,
you can just solve this for u2
over u1, and it would be 1.
AUDIENCE: I just don't
understand the format
you're writing it in up there.
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
back in my vector format.
I want to write the
mode shape as a vector.
You solve for u1.
So you can actually do this.
You know that that's true.
You could say, well,
the top one is 1,
and the bottom one
is the same as that.
So the mode shape
for mode one is that.
AUDIENCE: In the
answers, it says omega 1,
and the ratio of a1 and a2 is 1.
What are the a's?
PROFESSOR: I'm using u's.
And they used a's.
They're the elements of
the mode shape vector.
So if we had put in the other
natural frequency instead
of-- I may have just done
too many steps here at once.
So our first equation
looks like minus omega
squared plus h minus k/m.
And the second
equation is minus k/m.
And over here is minus
omega squared plus h again.
That's our matrix.
When we add these two
matrices together,
the minus omega
squared m plus k,
that's what it looks like when
you add elements together.
And these are two
equations and two unknowns.
We're looking for the answer for
some u1, u2 multiplied by this.
So you multiply this out.
You get minus omega squared
plus h u1 minus k/m u2.
And now let's plug in the
second natural frequency.
So omega 2 squared is that.
And solve for the
second mode now.
Plug it in here.
We get minus g/L minus
2k over m plus h,
which is g/L, plus k/m plus, and
that's times u1, plus k/m u2.
All it's equal to 0.
This cancels this, this,
and this, plus 1 minus 2.
I get a minus k/m out of this.
So I have this whole thing gives
me minus k/m u1 plus k/m u2.
AUDIENCE: It's supposed
to be minus k/m.
PROFESSOR: I agree with you.
Where did I make the mistake?
AUDIENCE: The very first
line, it's minus k/m u2.
PROFESSOR: Ah, good, all right.
And this is equal to 0.
The k over m's cancel out.
And you find that this implies
that u1 equals minus u2.
And so the mode shape for mode
two you could write as u1.
And u2 is minus u1, if you will.
And it's obvious
if you factor out
u1 you get u1 and
a 1 minus 1, right?
So now you've solved for
the second mode shape.
If this had been more
than a two by two,
like a three degree
of freedom system,
you'd have to use two
of the three equations
to get the ratio.
You'd get two equations
and three unknowns.
And at best, you can
find the two of them
in terms of the third.
And the third one would be u1.
You'd just divide
all the others by u1.
So you only get their ratios.
OK, so those are the
natural frequencies.
Those are the mode shapes.
Let's demonstrate it.
Let's look at it.
This is basically the system.
And you now know the
mode shapes, the two mode
shapes of this thing, are 1,
1 for the first mode and 1,
minus 1 for the second mode.
And the modal expansion
theorem depends on this fact
that the mode shapes form
a complete independent set
of vectors that are
orthogonal to one another.
A weighted sum of all the
mode shades of the system
can represent any allowable
motion of the system.
Any possible motion
of the system
can be written as a weight
of-- so any way I can displace
these things, a little bit
here, a little bit there,
I can write that position as a
weighted sum of those two mode
shapes.
So let's say I want to
have initial conditions
on displacement, on r
theta, 1 0 and theta
2 0, no initial velocities,
just initial angles.
And I want that initial
condition vector to be 1, 0.
I'm claiming I can write
that as a sum of something 1,
1 plus another
something 1, minus 1.
So what do c1 and c2 have
to be to give me that?
You ought to be able to kind of
do that by inspection, almost.
For example, just
try them equal.
And what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So 1/2
and 1/2, right?
Great, so to satisfy this, it's
1/2 1, 1 plus 1/2 1, minus 1.
And I've just
illustrated the fact
that you can represent
an arbitrary deflection,
allowable deflection
of the system,
as a weighted sum of
the two mode shapes.
So that says if I make
the initial-- now,
this says that theta 1
is 1, and theta 2 is 0.
And what it's telling
us is by modal analysis,
that means the
resulting motion should
look like the response
to initial conditions
where I have equal amounts
of each of those two modes.
So there ought to be some
vibration at omega 1,
and there ought to be equal
amount of vibration at omega 2.
Agreed?
OK, let's try it.
I'll hold one of these in place,
and I'll deflect the other one
and let go.
Now, that one's stationary,
and this one's moving.
And a few cycles later,
this one will be stationary,
and that one will be moving.
So what you're observing,
could that motion,
what you're seeing,
possibly be a mode,
a natural mode by itself?
No, because the
different proportions
are changing, right?
This is the sum of
two modes-- exactly
as you said, equal
amounts of each.
And when you do
that, and you have
two things of equal amplitude,
two cosine omega t like terms
of equal amplitude and
different frequencies,
you get a phenomenon
known as beating.
That's what this is.
Beating means that one vibrates,
and then it will get small.
And then you'll see it build
up again, and then get small.
So if you watch
either one of these,
it's doing large and stopping.
And the other one is doing
the same thing, but actually
90 degrees out of phase.
So what we're really seeing is
that the motion of this system,
this is 1, 1, 1/2 and 1, 1
cosine omega 1 t plus a 1/2 1,
minus 1 cosine omega 2 t.
That's the total
response of the system.
Let's look at the
first line of this.
This says 1/2 cosine omega
1 t plus 1/2 cosine omega
2 t should be equal to the
motion we call theta 1 of t.
That's the first row here.
This is theta 1, theta 2.
So the first row of this,
the first equation, is that.
And two equal amplitude cosines
of different frequencies
you can write as cosine
omega 2 minus omega 1
over 2 times t times cosine
omega 1 plus omega 2 over 2 t.
This beat phenomena that you're
seeing when you plot this--
and this is now for theta 1.
It starts off at some amplitude.
And the actual motion you
see, if you watch it, it
does what I'm drawing right now.
This envelope is this term,
the difference frequency
divided by 2.
What's inside is that term.
And this is called beating.
This is the equation
for beating.
When you add two equal
amplitude cosines together,
they give you something
that looks like that.
And one period of
the beat is how long
it takes to go through one
full cycle from here to here.
That's one period of the beat.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did
you get those terms
with the omega 2 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
just trig identity.
You add-- you just
go back to your trig,
take cosine of a
plus cosine of b.
You'll find out you can do that.
I don't have time
to go through that.
And the other one is
a 1/2 cosine omega 1
t minus 1/2 cosine omega 2 t.
And that turns out to be
sine omega 2 minus omega 1
over 2 t times sine omega 1 plus
omega 2 over 2 quantity times
time.
And that means that
the theta 2 coordinate,
what it looks like when you draw
it, is 90 degrees out of phase.
It's the same thing, but it
starts at 0 here and beats.
But it starts 0 where
that one started here.
And that's what--
if you look at one.
So if that's theta 1 and this
is theta 2, when one of them
stops, that's one of these
lines, one of these equations.
And the other equation
is 90 degrees.
So that one's stopped right now.
Pi over 2 later, this
one will be stopped.
So the beat behaves
like sine in one case,
and behaves like cosine
in the other case.
One of these needs a minus sign.
That's a plus, minus and
plus, minus and plus.
Now what if you have
unequal amounts?
We have exactly equal
amounts of the two modes.
If you have unequal
amounts of the two modes,
then it's not going
to be 1/2 and 1/2.
What if it's like 1 and 0.1?
Then do you see full beats?
Does one come to a stop?
If they're not
equal, you'll find
that the sums of the two
motions, the envelope
will look like this.
It'll be modulated.
Each one's motion
will look like that.
It'll never go to 0 quite.
But that's beating.
How are we doing on time?
We're good.
And let's see, we said
the one natural mode is
the two opposite one another.
So if I start, go equal
amounts in opposite directions
and let go, it ought to
just sit there and vibrate
all day like that-- no beats.
Because it's the 1,
0 case over there.
And actually, this
is the 0, 1 case.
This is 1, minus 1.
I gave an initial displacement
in exactly the shape
of the second mode.
And that means the
two contributions
are that one of
those constants is 0.
There's no mode one in this.
It's only mode two.
And it'll sit here all day long
and vibrate just in mode two.
And if I displace it in
the shape of mode one only,
it'll vibrate.
And that one's harder do.
Because I have to move it
exactly the same amount.
That's mode one.
And it should vibrate
all day long on mode one.
Because now there's no mode
two involved in that one.
You see it's already getting
a little out of phase.
It's hard for me to move my
hands exactly the same amount.
So I have a little bit of
the other mode in there.
But you'll never see either one
of these come to a full stop.
It's actually doing that when
you get a little contamination
of the second mode in there.
OK, so I've posted on Stellar
a little two-page sheet
that just gives you step by
step how to do a modal analysis.
It's just cookbook.
Modal analysis is easy.
You do it all on the computer.
You just put your m
matrix and your k matrix,
and you just crank stuff out.
We did multimodal
analysis yesterday
just from initial conditions.
Next Tuesday, we'll
do modal analysis
assuming you've got harmonic
excitation and steady state
vibration and do
that kind of thing.